okay for people joining this livestream
we are talking about language and
completeness and consistency is useful
from language we've got it seems a
variety of different topics for today
okay documentation of fare ogz version
of with now i'm we cannot document this
until the coloring stuff has been done
we've said that in previous versions and
we need to uphold to that so you know i
don't know how i don't consider it
totally urgent but we really can't
document it until the coloring is
working that makes sense to people
well I was hoping to try to look at it
before the meeting to see really when
the pedal hits the metal how much work
it would be but I got sucked into some
other more urgent stuff so okay well so
let's find that out and let's loop back
to that question then okay there's
nothing more to say uh just just remind
me so are you saying that as long as
it's not showing red even if it's not
contextualizing all the way down that
that that might be reason to go forward
possibly you know I think we're all
pretty much in agreement that we can
make the red go away for twelve one
without competing with any other
front-end features making it you know
fully Ness and all that stuff then
you're potentially having to choose
between this and some other front-end
seat well the code assistance features
are the most important things we're
delivering from the front end as far as
I'm concerned apart from high DPI
support so we cannot compete with those
so if we can prevent it going red I
suppose we can put it in we can document
it okay okay I'm not I'm not thrilled
about it but why doesn't John find out
how hard it actually is well I already
know it's not easy the only question is
is it hard or very hard
okay fine
well coloring code which is not an easy
body of code to work I understand since
we're here what um
if we had contextual machine learning
based well won't be coloring it'll be
Auto suggests is that like really hard
to deal with or not somebody gave you a
neural net that you run to decide some
rankings for autocompletes based
context could you deal with that the
most the first question I would ask is
how is access that they're all nets it's
C code assume it to assume it to lump of
C code something like that okay so
because the machine learning okay right
I understand
but Mike what it's not gonna be a very
complicated piece of C code so it's
gonna be a lump of code and you feed it
a string of characters and they'll tell
you something right so the machine
learning people believe that the
front-end team believes that they can't
use any machine learning stuff so
somebody has to break out of that that
misimpression well well they can't use
it in the form that it's available in
the kernel that's correct it will be an
exported lump of C code that's what I'm
saying
right but I'm just saying I'm wondering
if that is the source of their missing I
agree that that's a possible
misunderstanding
I already addressed that with them they
still thought there was a problem well
it's it's certainly an understanding or
misunderstanding that I had as well so
all right but I can I can talk to them
and let them know about stuff on our
roadmap which makes this a lot more
straightforward okay do you want to
review
the futurist documentation sure shall be
so much happier when we when we properly
motorized the salt pallets thing so it's
the futurist usage in the futurist note
and then I will need to add an example
after it's you know diffused can I do
the obsessive thing oh well something's
broken about that deaf to thing there
I'll take a look but otherwise I have no
problem with this it looks well written
okay okay let's talk about graphics row
so do I need to run this oh okay okay
right so probably we should start off
with Brett
where's Brett nassim not in this meeting
for some reason we need Brett yeah I
find out yeah cuz this is not a fruitful
discussion if he's normally here which
is why I'm surprised
okay what is it taking its time is it
running graph data yes right the how I
see it's running across a whole bunch of
different graphs it's got to look that
in I'm hoping that there will be nice
new I mean I don't mind these that those
um those progress things were okay to me
it's just that we need to standardize
progress stuff
okay
all right well let's
to the next item and wait and wait for
Brett to show up it's described as a
notice of interest ring right so if you
look at the ref page for from digits it
says it's the inverse of integer string
and they think integer digits is that
the right function so like the first
note
I see from digits wow I didn't even know
we had a thing that constructed
something from Roman numerals okay right
now the problem is right so the right so
in the beginning there were there was
just different numerical basis oh I know
so we add it then we added giorgia and
Ethiopian and things like this right and
base64 and base 58 and you know all
right so the question is do we want to
support the from digits for Ethiopian
for example and the answer is it'd be
lovely to do that and we must have code
for doing that because we do that's what
we don't have okay so I think I don't
think anybody disagrees that in
principle we should now my understanding
from francisco's we have code for some
of these but not all of them so
Francisco should speak into what exactly
we have and you know doesn't make
another another sorry another small
comment the discovery of what this list
is okay you know what we should be doing
it's this is an idea okay when we have a
list like this in documentation we
should put this in the data repository
okay that list basically or the list of
all of these variants and we should in
these notes just say this list is
available in the data repository in this
place see what I'm saying and we should
call it something like integer string
variants or something like integer and
that way if you need to like I was about
to just try something and try it in all
these possible bases in all these
possible number systems right but I
don't have a good way to do that
am I making sense
mm-hmm and I've been annoyed by this
many times that we've got a list like
this and the only thing I can do is
scrape this page get what I'm saying
mm-hmm right
you understand so what I'm saying is
that did you understand what I said yes
okay do we think it's a good idea
only if it's automatically scraped what
do you mean by that
like you know say during the
documentation build process somehow it
auto generates the data repository stuff
from the table and the docs sources it
will be nice if it did that yeah I mean
otherwise it's we sort of have multiple
places that you have to maintain well I
understand that but that the same thing
is true for example with syntax coloring
right now and with um with option
completion so we do have a scraping
process for those things we would have
to make sure that this gets done you
know in a way that's um right in a
consistent way but that's not an excuse
to not provide it for our users it's a
reason why we need to build a system
that does that properly is it I don't
think it's the best place though I think
the nice place to put it is just
something because what I've just
realized which I hadn't really realize
before is that this is the place you're
gonna look for it is right here in the
documentation right it's not like you're
gonna look for this in some other place
you're gonna look for it in the
documentation you're gonna and say how
do I get it why would you look for it
and that's my whole point that's why I
was saying did you understand what I
said
because what I'm saying is the whole
point is you put a note right off to
this that says this table is available
in the data repository right well you
could have note could just as easily
read is available from wolfram link as
well from language data you know entity
comma property it could yes it could I
agree it could that seems to me like a
more sensible place I mean I use Wolfram
language
to look up you know options well it's
not unreasonable it's not an
unreasonable point let's see what the
design would look like there okay I
wonder also if we could put that in
language data deep its this list evolves
with different versions that we could
get for each version which is the list
of viable arguments well we don't have
that for other stuff here so what would
we call it I mean we would call it
something like we'll call it we would
have to have it be an association
because these things could have multiple
multiple arguments that have strings so
it could be called something like
argument values or something and then it
could be I would call it string
arguments okay and it's weird right
because consider spring replace you know
string string arguments obviously as is
should just be not applicable or
something like that no that's wrong and
then and then similarly for other
functions you might have more than one
argument that is fine named string
arguments then it's about how about
argument choices no no my point was you
have to specify is it the second
argument that you're talking about her
the third argument for the first
argument that's right that's why I was
saying yeah that's why I was saying it
should be an association right yes okay
right
so then we would have a note that says
it's specified in Wolfram language data
of in that case integer string argument
choices I really don't like argument
choices because that is a sound suite in
general and we'll okay okay okay okay
well what would you like named string
named string arguments I think no
because that suggests it's the arguments
are that suggests it's the arguments
that are named that's not what's
happening
it's the values in the arguments that
are named but they're ones that are
named strings I know that I know that
but but that's not but the people won't
read it that way um I mean I still I'm
sorry I'm still coming back to it should
be in the function repository because I
think this is kind of an a hack to put
it in here argue for me again why it
should be a more from language traitor
rather than an okay to repository yes
that's where we could in the options and
what options though it's not the option
values are not their only option names
not the option values we don't have any
information on option values here we
think we have the defaults no we don't
oh I think options is is I mean take a
look at what what it is in a sense the
system must know there's a common option
values over a wait wait wait what
happened here well you didn't give it an
entity
yeah the entity is a string it's the
string integer string shouldn't we allow
the symbol name as well maybe maybe not
well right it's entity Wolfram language
data right
okay so that's just the options as you
would get from options of the of the VM
right but that's also what's listed in
the documentation right in the table in
the documentation right you see those
those options and their values what do
you get there's also a common option
values prop property of Wolfram language
data okay let's take a look at that
I didn't realize that was available well
that's interesting isn't it so common
arguments with no no it's not
necessarily common it's it's some
respond to what the completions for
those options are this does or does not
does how about named argument values or
argument values but I think named to
just make it clear that we're giving the
string ones and not arbitrary arguments
what about true and false what do you
mean well I mean you know is this really
just really you know restricted to
strings or is it any you know of the
special forms that make it especially
identified in a table mm-hmm I see yeah
I think it would be more flexible to put
these in the data repository because I
think there's so many different cases
here of different kinds of things that
can happen I mean if I look at sound
note my favorite example of one that
that I just drives me crazy that you
can't get that list okay now do we put
it in one list here if we had it in the
data repository you know do we list
separately we got a list you see it's
not so simple because we need to say
Stiles percussion events those probably
should be separate right where you want
a list of percussion events you want a
list of styles those are all values for
that string but they are differently
configured values and it will be really
good to have them be separate right on
the other hand if we put it in the data
repository and not in from language data
if I want to find out what are all well
maybe if it's an association this
wouldn't really work anyway but I was
going to say because I use this all the
time if I want to find out what what
functions understand you know Ethiopian
as an argument okay that's a different
thing that you're not gonna be able to
find it out this way that's a
complicated thing I agree that's
interesting but that's a that's a kind
of thing that you want to find out right
but cuz I consider I can certainly use
Wolfram language data to find out you
know which functions take a given option
right I really think what it should do
is this should have a link possible and
this should have some pretty stylized
link saying typical possible Styles
paren listed in wool from data
repository something like that and
that's a link and you just go to that
link and you're on the page if we just
made it easy to copy the table out as a
data set or something you mean a click
to copy yeah something along those lines
how would anybody discover that I agree
that's nice that's a nice idea to have
this beaker to copy copy that
now and you know fit it with normal and
well this happens to be a something
somewhat reasonable I had no idea that
would work right because this is just a
normal grid and not fancy people but
well you but even in the integer string
case with you know a little bit of care
you can select a column well let's try
it I mean but this is a hack you know if
this was a click to copy yeah who knows
what this thing is okay fine I managed
to get did I get it in fact here yeah I
mean you got a an end by one one by an
array you'd need to flatten it before
you I not only make systems go that far
now a long percent okay now why is that
invalid system Ethiopia Oh correct oh
that's probably a typo in the
documentation right yeah if every
variant I've tried hasn't worked them I
think it's just a bug well let's go look
at the source Francisco go look at the
source find out what it should be um but
I also a
agree that most of most if not all of
the other seemed to be the an form not
that not the country name form yes right
okay anyway let's decide what we're
gonna do with this you know to me I mean
I didn't even think of the I tried this
before and it's a completely not worked
this copy it out thing I mean that was a
while ago I admit um so I mean I really
favor having something where it's sort
of an easy ok Heath y'all pick all right
well let's go just go change this why um
can we make sure that whether it appears
anywhere else please that's a that's a
disappointing bug but anyway okay anyway
okay so our two choices are I don't like
the Wolfram language solution I don't
like the Wolfram language data solution
the idea of having a click to copy is
nice and I support that but I don't
think people are going to discover that
most of the time well what if you have a
button which says copy values that would
be fine right cuz I mean we need some
intelligence from the dark spilt system
right because it needs to know do you
want to say copy values or do you want
to write it in a program not with those
values do you want to have something
which is the the thing that generates
those values every time in other words
if you write this program and then you
come back five years later and there's
more number systems here you get what
I'm saying yeah um yeah
I'm I think we need some standardized
way to say available as mm-hmm I really
favor putting these things in the data
repository I think it's a you know it's
the standard place where we're just
having blobs of data available
I mean alternatively we have to have
something well I think the Wolfram
language data thing is a hack because I
think it's gonna end up being no because
we can't segment the things for example
for those music things between
percussion and other stuff now I thought
we were supposed to put it in there
actually okay so listen um I guess this
is for Devon now um we need to figure
out what are the big chunks of tabular
data like this in the in the in the
documentation and then we need to talk
to Brian about how we can tag it so that
it's easy to update I mean we could
simply put a note in the documentation
saying update the data repository if you
update this um somebody is typing an
area could you meet yourself please um
that's
whoever's typing please mute yourself um
okay
so okay what what do people have to say
about this how do we handle parameterize
settings like what that's the point
that's why we should put this in the
data repository because we don't have a
standard way to do this in a case like
this we're just putting envelope here
all of these right was list blah comma n
we don't know what to do and it's going
to have to be done on a case-by-case
basis and
other cases where there's already a
built-in discovery mechanism like
Packard's or at least some packets yeah
well that's the point some so I would
say that it's a it's a you know it's a
discretionary thing that is in the
documentation we decide this is a take a
look if this only had three entries I
wouldn't put it in the data repository
or is it better to do a quick to copy
what do you think guys think I mean if
it's clicked a copy is still not solving
the parametrized problem again well not
necessarily I mean it could come in as a
you know placeholder yeah I could it
could okay this is probably a discussion
with Brian but I really want to see this
actually resolved so Devon this is your
your thing go talk to Brian I think
choices are click to copy with some
indicator a button that says copy list
or data repository entries you
understand yeah so go and report back to
either LD or this meeting with the
result from that
yeah um okay now here you are saying
from digits will not go backwards from
Ethiopia is that correct correct any
string argument other than Roman okay so
I happen to remember that the summer
camp a couple of years ago somebody
wrote some code to do some of these
maybe this is a good project I mean this
does seem like a fairly straightforward
project isn't it or am i confused III I
mean the the only tricky bit would be
hooking it up right without slowing
everything else down well I assume it
calls this and the case where somebody's
got to put that in but it's obviously
going to call this in the case where it
sees a second argument of ethiop ik
right now can you comment on this right
so there were a couple of cases where
may we need a better implementation like
for example for base64 all these 58 what
I think it's worth having an optimized
implementation of course I agree because
that's the broad simple blockchain
people will use it very fast code in the
other cases like for example Ethiopia
top-level code that you said function so
which of these do we have code for so
they're like half of them that are
trivial because they are like on
placement of digits but others need have
some kind of algorithm okay fine so can
you specify which ones need an algorithm
and let me know that and we'll see what
the people at the summer school or
summer camp want to implement some of
these seems like good project okay yes I
can separate at least okay but I believe
that the one for like Korean or
something was already done by somebody
so you should it they started that but
they'd never finish well um okay well
find out what okay was it that hard not
sure if it was hard or it was a matter
of thing I'd say um let's see pausing
and it's a string output from
okay um okay if you can send that to me
and I'm actually going to be writing up
the list of projects in the next day or
two so if you send that to me soon that
will be good okay and the ones where
it's just digit replacement I mean you
could just you know get someone just
write that code making sense
sure okay all right we go back to this
topic here the this thing Brett are you
here now yes I'm here okay so this
disaster so can you explain what's going
on here
so graphics row starting in v12 is
attempting to make is as you'll recall
all the frames line up when you have a
bunch of plots right I don't want to see
text so I just want say plot label well
why is it doing that I mean um what
happened here
so anyway okay so what graphics row is
doing in graphics written graphics
column is it's making sure that all the
things have the same image padding
around them because then the actual
content will all line up nicely right as
opposed to what so if you do the myself
can you show me what this looked like
before sure you just send it to me in a
second
so you're saying if I say alignment
arrow Center here mm-hmm what still
didn't work well that's cause you took
out the text cell okay Eric was using
the text cell to have it auto line wrap
oh I see I see I see I see I have to say
I'm not entirely thrilled with screen
shots in Mojave really I like the new
shift command fave so so it puts the
little icon in the bottom right corner
after you do that and I want to drag it
in the mail and it like loses it I see
are you sending this to me yes I just
did okay okay so that's the 11:3
behavior and so what do I need to I need
to do that with the whole jazz here to
see okay so this is the behavior now
which looks pretty terrible okay
what's the issue here okay
so what happens is like I was starting
to save is that we have things line up
by making sure that all the image
padding on each side is the same right
now so if you have if you think back to
like you know say a plot where it goes
from zero to one and a plot where it
goes from zero to a million then things
don't line up because a million is
bigger than one and that's affected you
know that's controlled by the image
padding mm-hmm and and so we figure out
how much image padding the million takes
and we apply it to the plot that goes
from zero to one and everything lines up
and so that's what's being done here as
well but what happens is the way that I
was measuring image padding is including
the space used by the plot label but the
plot label actually draws in addition to
the image padding and so when it was
setting the image padding according to
like a double height you know a two line
plot label then you were sort of ending
up with the plot label an empty amount
of space corresponding to the same
height as the plot label and then the
you know main content was being shrunk
down because of the overall size so the
bug isn't it yes that's what I said in
the email okay so you're fixing the bug
yes I was doing that this morning okay
fine so there's nothing to discuss there
is there anything to discuss here I
don't think so
fine let's move on excellent okay
preview of I can eyes okay so this is
apparently something you claimed you
wanted although I do the last meeting we
decided something else so can can you
remind me what the issue was here this
was a question of being able to mouse
over and get a preview of I can eyes
right I think an ILD meeting you
mentioned you click on that and it'll
give
you the preview you wanted a box-like
structure but you could just expand and
give preview of the icon eyes items like
nice items and on clicking that back
it'll just collapse like how it is right
right so what now I remind you that what
we decided at the previous meeting where
we were talking about naming icon eyes
objects was that if you clicked on not
on the plus minus but on the you know
the name part then it selects the whole
thing and brings up a raft I guess it's
the term you know where you and I guess
one of the options is that you can you
know edit the name or remove the name of
an ionized object okay so wait a minute
so I remember that also and that's a
good idea but maybe these aren't
inconsistent maybe the raft could have
two pieces of information in it okay but
what was the preview idea see I wasn't
in this meeting so yeah okay so in Aldie
meeting what you said was this was I
mean this was a but like we had code
about flip for you let me think what it
is it's about so if it is 3.14
you know dot dot which was like a flip I
can send you the code which we were
discussing yes that was that was in
connection with that with these numbers
that are incomplete right yes and you
type something like that can happen for
icon eyes as I mean what we did did with
numbers so the idea with numbers was
this was being able to get like
something like this and being able to
know that that was what you see is not
what's actually
being stored underneath right and so
what did we what was the idea there that
you click the number or that you hover
on the button you get a raft or what
there was ellipsis we we discussed about
ellipses we didn't decide anything we
discussed about having ellipses and let
me send you definitely do not want an
ellipses by default we just want the
numbers I mean that would be crazy that
would destroy the whole point of this
you know short number form what we want
is when you mouse over it it does
something right you want to click
somewhere see the first elements you
really need to get out of the habit of
discussing typesetting user interface
things in ILD it's the wrong sort of
people should just be discussing that
here or in user assistance where well
sorry I mean that's why we have notes
and things I'm not seeing anything I'm
just I'm just suggesting this will be
more efficient for you if you send these
things to the right places to begin with
well yes but you know these things come
up in connection with something else and
that's why okay what does this do round
eyes what is this doing so there was a
code I'm sending you example as well so
do around eyes on FF which I just sent
you so when you saw the example you you
mentioned that this could also go
yes and then I'm clicking that ellipsis
it yeah expands like that and you were
you you were saying that you know
something like this on clicking the
ellipsis there in icon eyes it should
you preview in that box itself
not unlike realize it this does seem to
me to make quite a bit of sense your
understanding it I this actually well I
guess I guess you're starting with in
imprecise numbers to begin forget about
the numbers case but we're not talking
about the numbers case here we're
talking about the icon eyes case and the
question is whether this if you click
here you click on the initial thing here
should you get something which sort of
blows it out into something slightly
bigger well but this is not blowing it
out into something slightly bigger right
what is it
would that this around eyes thing right
it's showing you the complete thing well
in that particular case but I that's
that's the spirit that wasn't what I had
in mind for recognize I see right but
but if it does that then had then you've
just a I don't think really that it's
that useful and be you know I think that
you know that's fundamentally
incompatible with name you know the
naming idiom which i think is more
important so maybe there it gives you a
raft which allows you to do that sorry
sorry sorry i spaced out first I can
excuse me I got to start to buy
something could you could you come say
that again right so I think that you
know using up the the click on the main
thing action to you know blow it up is
the wrong thing okay what do you think
it should do well I think it should I
mean
right so our idea from last time was
that it should you know select it and
give you a raft
why do you need most draw have to come
up on hover not on selection selection
is useful though I mean we're not doing
anything else when you click on it I
know we're suggesting that you do this
when you click on it that was I'm
suggesting the he I mean right now I can
I steal the way the mouse click to do
nothing instead of selection and now
you're proposing you steal away the
mouse click to do something entirely
different instead of selection to select
stuff okay but it's not selecting right
now look within them within the icon but
the but the plan was to have it do that
do what what kind of selection it would
click active control would simply select
the entire icon eyes block at which
point you could conveniently do a copy
for example I mean right now if you want
to copy a nice blob you have to very
carefully you know drag from the left
side to the right side or want to copy
anything like this I have to drag from
the left side to the right side so I see
so in this case what if you double click
here well if you if single click doesn't
select why should look I think that
being able to see a preview of what's
inside the icon eyes would be really
really useful I mean this preview is
kind of lame well we can I think it
would be more useful than to add it to
death I mean but I think it's a natural
thing for people to do to click it see a
preview click it again get rid of the
preview I think that's what the plus
sign is for yeah point I just think it's
more natural I mean I'm not that wild
about the plus sign and I would
perfectly happy to not have a plus sign
to have it be that there's I mean to
change the UX slightly and to have two
things happen one you click on the thing
to get it to pop out and two you get a
Roth that allows you other actions but
I'm with John and constantly copy
pasting things from all sorts of cells
in the front end and and I don't want
selection to be harder yeah I mean I you
know I I really I really they really
think that this buffing earth is less
important than you know what about what
about if the pop out information is
available in the raft what about if I
hover it shows the summary and then
gives you a rename as a second item in
the raft possibly so sorry my iPad that
I was using zoom on overheated so what I
said was on hover give a raft the top
row of which is the puff out and the
second row of which is the rename
possibility so do are these rafts
available anywhere yet I mean well it's
no it's a the it's something that we're
definitely planning but the basic
functionality which requires attach
cells that attach to selections is not
yet done okay user accessible that's
what you're saying no not done we have
attached cells but we can't attach them
to arbitrary selections yet which is
what we really want to do here we can
attach them to a box so if your
selection corresponds to a box then yes
but that's we're and and it does for
this particular case but but how we were
wanting to implement is to be able to
attach the arbitrary selections
right so okay so there's an example of
one of these rafts even in the prototype
build that we could look at i'm
currently there isn't a lot you saying
there isn't oh there is well that was a
question of whether there is or is not
and no no okay because I guess in part
it's hard to I I mean the closest
analogous behavior would be would be the
kinds of things that spring up when you
select for example an image or an image
3d or graph or should i camera if we do
it for graphs or not but they know along
those lines them but smaller in this
particular case so you're proposing that
on selection you bring up a raft of some
kind not on hover right and that you
would routinely see selection rafts I
mean for lots of selections but
depending on the actual selection the
contents of the raft may be different
you know I mean honestly I'm not wild
about this plus sign and it's I mean
these actions we need the UH Nikon eyes
action it's useful to see some of these
things here particularly things like the
bite count but those are things which I
will be happy to you know have a little
information button to get to that comes
up in a raft but I don't know some why
you don't want a raft on hover well I
mean for one thing I think we have too
many rafts on hover its yeah I turn off
hover because they're always getting in
my way I mean we already have cases
where you know we're fielding accidental
clicks and the more rafts the more
accidents they're going to going to be
it's not a design I've ever been
strongly in favor of okay
I mean are you suggesting that we might
have a selection based draft here I'm
suggesting that we would probably have a
selection based raft for most selections
only the content of the raft would
differ depending on the case it example
it would be nice I mean if we come
before that but but also the nice thing
about you know about that is we can
control a little bit more you know the
the kind of mouse-over sort of thing and
we can even we can even dim the raft
down when you move away from the
selections so that it's not obscuring
the content behind it yeah that's nice
I mean I look I agree I think our being
able to get to information get to
documentation from the thing based on
selection would be really nice mm-hmm
okay
so look I think we need to figure out
what would be the shallow representation
of a of an icon ice thing and then I
kind of agree with this idea of you know
a clique based raft
mm-hmm okay okay maybe I will want to
push for some change in that plus sign
behavior yeah I I don't know what the
shallow representation would be either
ever we just punting that question for
the time being or well I think somebody
should try and figure it out I mean it's
gonna be some short or shallow type
thing um I mean big question for me is
is it pre computed or computed on demand
well certainly right now it's not pre
computed I mean we need to yeah I would
think we should pre compute it right
which would be creating yet another
backwards incompatible I can I switch
you know for something that's allegedly
boy oh boy wait wait why is it backward
incompatible it's just putting something
else in the Association for the
organized object which will presumably
be ignored another version it's possible
we might be able to do it without a
backward compatibility I'd have to look
at the boxes for I can eyes more closely
guys right there's a risk but it's not a
guarantee it depends on the boxes
why doesn't that work I'm right-clicking
here and I'm saying on I always
selection oh yes that is that is
something that is I've discovered before
and I thought we reported this but we
did a report about it is certainly a
reported bug because I'm pretty sure I
reported it okay okay fine
all right a question from our livestream
here there's a session about clicking
hold but we can't do cooking hold that's
a mobile metaphor Ian asks would it be
possible to password protect
ionised content interesting we've not
thought about that I mean let me see
what what would it what would it do if
you did ctrl shift e right I mean what
you'd need to do what we would suspend
method to allow you to specify some sort
of arbitrary deserialization function so
that you you know put in an encoded
password protected object why he's put
an encrypted thing sure
now I mean once one person has decrypted
it then yeah I mean so the scenario
would be you give you a notebook to
people let's see that the problem is I
don't see how this could work I mean if
what if my password protected you mean
that you can't get to the content you
can only use the value of the content
the problem is it's way too easy to
intercept that rates I mean to see the
content in plain text in the notebook
yes one could protect against that but
as soon as I say you know thing equals
this right yeah I'm getting the content
right I think there's no added value
beyond using you know encrypt of
expression and then just sending the
encrypted object in a notebook and then
the receive recipient has to you know I
think that the thing that interest is to
be able to have something where it is a
different kind of thing that's being
asked for it's a thing whose value gosh
that's a very bizarre concept value
right because well I mean if the value
is accessible then you can just put it
in a cell by itself and evaluate it and
voila right so Bob my live stream is
asking couldn't you hide it'll eat all
files inside an icon yeah so the I mean
the front end security system such as it
is is is going to kick in a place for
you know anything that it can't
positively identify as being safe code
which includes for example you know the
you know unencrypted inor you know to
expression or something like that
so that will be but that still doesn't
solve the problem of having something
behind the icon that you could use in a
program but never get the unencrypted
version of that stuff right what I'm
saying is if the front end can't read it
can't read the program in plain text
it's going to it's going to advise you
it's a security problem
no I understand but I think this problem
of I mean this is this is the world of
like Floyd homomorphic encryption so to
speak can you do operations on something
which is encrypted because as soon as
the thing ever gets decrypted you can go
in and somehow trace what's going on in
the code you don't need to disassemble
or anything you just need yeah I don't
think that's workable I would love to
make a something that is workable now in
terms of the renamed offering renamed in
the right-click icon is that a good idea
I think it's a decent idea I don't think
that right took the right-click menu is
overly full right now I don't see why we
shouldn't allow a rename I can eyes
thing in the right-click menu on on I
can I agree okay okay so that's some I
mean that's another way to do the rename
okay so I will warn you this is
something we just threw and because
other agenda items have to be removed
because somebody's on PPO and you
mentioned you needed Jeremy for this
meeting and Jeremy had to leave okay but
I I think if the general point is to
parameterize indentation and exported
stuff yes we obviously need a way to do
that but this isn't it okay I mean I you
know it will be some named option I
would assume I just don't know how you
how to parameter has annotation I mean
this is like code beautification styles
I mean don't we want about I mean don't
we want to say an option that's called
something like indentation theme an
analogy to plot theme
and then you can give all kinds of names
for this like I said this is something
entered together so this is David that's
my suggestion is some kind of
indentation theme it's not obviously
silly I'm not sure in the email he also
mentions that he basically wants to
specify what the string is himself it's
not useful so by the way just to be
clear it's not just the indentation
you're losing you're losing comments too
this is thematically similar to convert
to standard form sorry what are you
talking about
I mean you're talking about the round
trip around through JSON or something
no I'm talking about the fact that what
it's doing is is taking boxes and
converting them to an expression and
throwing the expression in I can eyes
we're not talking about I can eyes
anymore
there's nothing to do with I can eyes
yeah the different topic John well
that's a good point sorry sorry I didn't
catch I thought you were talking about
we're talking about indentation a
preview if I can eyes I didn't okay you
completely lost it here we're talking
about indentation options for export
functions oh oh no because no that's
that's what it was because I miss
identified this because there was a
discussion I guess this wasn't it about
preserving into indentation for I can
eyes that's what it was but that that is
a good point yeah yeah yeah okay okay
but hold on let's talk about that well
that's impossible
okay right because what does it do it
creates an expression and it sticks that
expression inside of the icon
expressions are don't have indentation
they're just expressions its own fortune
because it would be quite nice because
it will be a way of essentially doing
code folding and as it is you can't code
fold and preserve the formatting of your
code you see what I'm saying yes yeah
well I think we'd have to support two
kinds of icon eyes because we can't do
that generally with icon eyes it would
be a terrible hit to the efficiency of
being able to recognize large things
that were never represented in a
notebook in the first place but I
suppose one could say that you know if
it was in a notebook in the first place
you know then maybe you're not losing
too much because the boxes were there
one point in time and you could find a
different representation which isn't
lossy on the boxes maybe I think that
should be looked at because I think it's
an interesting idea that if the thing
has non-default for my thing and you ask
to icon eyes mean you could even ask if
it has non default formatting you can
even ask at the time you icon eyes do
you want to preserve formatting oh I
hate I hate I hate I hate you just want
to do something you don't want to make
choices lazy to make the choices I agree
I've made similar points myself um but
the suggestion would be if it's small
and it was formatted in the notebook and
your icon izing by taking something
explicitly displayed in the notebook and
saying I can eyes it that it preserves
the boxes in the ionized structure so I
mean I'd want to talk with Lou about
this but it seems conceptually possible
okay it's a would you disagree with that
yeah I suppose it's not the halting
problem so I suppose it is possible well
I I'm only talking about interactive I
can eyes right right I understand that I
just I'm not sure it could be done and
then he sort of what
why doesn't John talk to Lou about that
and see whether he can come up with a
way that could be done I can't talk
about it again but this indentation
stuff um I kind of think indentation
theme is a better idea than invitation
string but I don't know whether the
people who are dealing with this problem
out here
well I mean Shawn's here and I'm here
seems to be an original I mean yeah I
mean like I said this is something that
was to replace something that I was
actually ready to discuss so I do have
something that I would like to discuss
if possible you know you might okay sure
go ahead although it a bit over time but
go ahead please so shadi and I were
looking at attachments in EML mbox again
and so the middle here is the email new
which is what we decided on after last
LCCC mhm and on the right is basically
my proposal I know that I want this
stuff I'm just not sure that it's named
properly so we created attachment lists
which used to be attachments and well we
dropped the left-hand side of the rule
which was the file name and now it's
just a list of expressions I don't like
it says so the expressions is useful but
sometimes you want the expression and
the file name for example so we have
this attachment data thing that has the
raw content but it's the raw encoded
content and it's base64 and not as
useful as the raw decoded content is a
byte string so the natural name will be
attachment rules that we had natural
that would be our natural name for the
thing that is actually well can there be
multiple attachments with the same name
yes so then that's the only choice I
mean it has to be a list with the
left-hand side of the rule being the
name the right-hand side being the bass
attachment rules has well not not so
much that as much as all of these
properties would be useful in an
association so lists are used
appointment you were taught it you you
yourself would add an attachment rules
right that that
before that correct yes just now this is
what I want to propose so right now we
have attachment data with just the raw
content and the rod encoded content I
want three things I want still the raw
data so that's what was attachment data
I want something that gives me the byte
string so I can call import string on it
however I please and I want something
that gives me the actual imported
content by default okay so these are
three associations which only differ in
one field yes how we present the content
this is for efficiency basically if we
gave you all these things in one thing
then there's no point in you know
separating them if you really just
wanted the byte string it'd be
inefficient to have already imported
everything which is why we dropped
attachment associations attachment
associations used to be this raw encoded
content as well as the imported content
but we've never exposed this raw byte
string which is the most useful thing
the decoded wasting with why is it the
byte string another byte array you mean
by to write here don't you should be a
byte array and it probably should be a
byte array but Vidor import byte array
is basically you know I don't care how
it's implemented matters is how it's
designed and it's retention so right as
a beta race by two over the space space
space space in the gotcha
um okay so we need to have wait so okay
so what you want to do is it you're
saying that in each case you also want
the name the mime type etc that you want
all those things in all these cases is
that right yes except for content
transfer encoding which is only useful
if it's actually still encoded but so if
you decoded it you still
to know the mimetype yeah you need them
on yes yeah you know what stuff
now we have a good conversion from mime
type to format to you so hypothetically
I could also add a field that interprets
the mime type as its Wolfram language
format okay so each one of these it
depends if you want what was in the
email exactly the raw contents that you
can do whatever you want with with
flexibility and efficiency or just let
it get imported as content I understand
but I don't think these names are great
too for distinguishing those cases I
agree the names we need to work on
there's also one other difference here
in attachment data previously it was
documented that by count was the number
of bytes in the raw encoded content
that's completely useless that's not
gonna be the size of the file when you
actually you know download your
attachment so for byte count in this raw
data one sure it should be the encoded
content maybe or maybe it should just
always be the decoded and we don't know
because you don't even have the decoded
content in the raw data case you're not
decoding anything you're leaving it in
the encoded form fine so byte count
makes sense to be the encoded content
but then for these cases all three of
them it makes sense for the baked out to
be the decoded byte count I agree
wait a minute all three or all two of
them all two three attachment summaries
is also highlighted here okay so that's
a yet of fourth case of how attachments
I mean really this is similar to it
feels a bit similar to something where
you would just give a list of elements
well you say well you have another sub
list and you're saying attack elements
that is exactly what this is getting at
and I have kind of two levels where this
would happen so for these attachment
associations if you're just looking for
the names and contents that would be a
sub element and that's on the plan to
implement we could do the same thing for
something like full message elements to
query specific he's efficiently
because right now if you ask for
multiple elements it's the transpose
thing that's not useful not the
associations that we want hold on hold
on hold on what what do you mean the
associations for oh you're saying in an
end box right yep I don't quite
understand this and you're saying that I
I'm not wild about this full message
elements followed by a sub case there um
and I suppose this actually be this I
don't
okay so full message elements let's just
import this is a Association for each
email right and we want this Association
to only contain some specific subset of
keys because this contains a lot of keys
well I don't tell me why that isn't just
you importing those elements like from
on subject because if we just import
multiple elements it comes back as this
transposed list of Lists which isn't
useful it's a list of little wait a
second but it's the from and the subject
for each email right this only has one
email in it what you want it to be you
wanted to be all the Fromm's and then
all the subjects I don't think I want
each email group together with its from
and subject in one Association maybe
this is a better example because right
now this is the wrong behavior for for
an inbox em box I mean for a single
email sure but for an EM box I don't
know Stan why it isn't because if you if
you asked for from right it would give
you the list of Fromm's right you guys
for just one element well but that's
okay so hold on hold on go ahead
hold on this is different an e ml for a
single email it's different from what it
should do for an M box isn't it only in
that we won't select by email here so if
this were for EML we would drop this but
because I understand that but I'm saying
that the behavior this whole transposing
behavior
you might want you want something
different because if you just want for a
single email you just say from comment
subject you just want a list of the from
and the subject you know double lists
know anything that's that's what we have
to do that doesn't make sense with the
syntax of import because then this thing
should be a sub elem if this is an alum
not a list of elam and if you want a
list of elements that is double list
okay so that's why there's a double list
all right okay fine fine okay so there's
double lists there but in the case where
of an M box okay so things like mail
responder function they just use the
individual elements here from and
subject and so on to me mail receiver
function and I'll receive a function yes
right but they are not also constrained
to the syntax for import that's existed
forever I understand but I'm saying that
for an M box I would have thought that
you're saying you want I see those are
multiple elements and multiple elements
are always returned as the list of this
element and then the list I get a good
but if we drill down into with sub
elements we can pick specific keys and
that's exactly what a sub element is for
we have an association with a bunch of
things and then the sub element would be
the subset of keys from that association
yeah so this applies both to picking
elements that are at the element level
for the EML or m box and then what for
attachments we do the same thing we can
drill into those keys for the
associations and you know after going
through many examples this is the piece
that has always been missing to make
this useful without having to do a bunch
of transposes or something sorry sorry
by the way I'm I'm I'm looking at your
toolbar again and thinking how much we
need that toolbar to be in the function
repository but anyway this is who made
that toolbox that's actually yes Julio's
made a bunch of changes to it
I am very fond of this bar very looks
very nice and it seems like it's
something that should be and is there a
reason it could not be in the function
repository it would involve learning
here to put something in the function
repository so I'm not sure that it makes
sense in the function repository because
it's not really a function I mean it's
you know enables her like it should
enable and disable it oh no no no it's
just a thing that would create a
notebook with that bar in it that that's
what the function would be by the way
that toolbar should also be looked at
when we're building you know we're
supposed to be building a default
toolbar for notebooks yes we are and
that toy is it's a very different kind
of focused I understand that but it has
some interesting things in it um anyway
so I'm glad it seems like we're
convinced with sub-elements the only
thing left that I need to figure out
then is the names for these three things
yeah okay so maybe Sean and I should
have a separate meeting to sort through
this and it sounds good to me
yes I mean the
yeah and you say you've used all three
of these cases Shawn yes I mean not
really so much the raw case which is the
one we already had but these two cases
are increasing they seem very useful um
I don't care if we drop the raw one but
by the way no no wait a second what one
comment that I have is the key name
should not always be content it should
be raw content it should be decoded
content see what I'm saying
and it should be whatever imported
caught you know decoded content then the
first one will be raw content I don't
know whether yeah I don't know whether
we want to say imported content then
that may may not be consistent with
something else how about just content I
would think just content they're angry
um let's see why not do the following
okay first one is attachment raw data
the second one is attachment decoded
data and the third one is just
attachment data this is actually
literally what I landed on the first
time okay is there a problem with it no
I guess the problem was I wasn't sure
you would like it oh well but you've got
it first time so yeah this is a very
good sign um I mean does anybody object
to this this seems pretty good I think
I'd want to review it and in the motor
should find it I will look at it some
more but provisionally let's assume this
is what we're gonna go with great I mean
I can always rename things yeah okay
good stuff all right talk to you soon
thank you all and thank you